افاد مراس الجزيره باطلاق اكثر من 30
صاروخا من جنوب لبنان باتجاه مواقع عسكريه
اسرائيليه في تلال كفرشوبا المحتله ومحيط
مطنه سعسع باتجاه كريات شمونه في الجليل
الاعلى وقال حزب الله انه استهدف اليه
عسكريه اسرائيليه داخل ثكنه راموت نفتالي
وحقق اصابه مباشره واضاف ان مقاتليه قصفوا
بالاسلحه المناسبه موقع السماق الاسرائيلي
في مزارع شبعه وتجمع للجنود في ثكنات
هونين ورامي وهيات اضاف الحزبه انه استهدف
المرابض مدفعيه العدو في خربه ماعر
بالاسلحه المناسبه وحقق فيها اصابات
مباشره في المقابل قصفت طائرات حربيه
ومسيرات اسرائيليه مناطق وبلدات في جنوب
لبنان وكانت القناه الثانيه عش
الاسرائيليه فادت في وقت سابق بسماع
انفجارات قرب مدينه حيفا نتيجه اعتراض
الدفاعات الجويه طائره مسيره اطلقت من
لبنان بعد انطلاق صفارات الانذار في عكا
وخليج حيفا كما افاد مراسل الجزيره
باعتراض صاروخين في سماء مدينه عكا
القديمه عقب دوي صفرات
الانذار